um pans are always like hard to deal  with so what i did was i put drawers of  pants our pins are in drawers right  below the cooktop so everything is like  right where you use it um put built-in  cutting board nothing too interesting  many of these things were revolutionary  at the time not very much now  my mixer is  on a little lift behind that was  pretty pretty nifty at the time  and then i put a vegetable sink so my  triangle is kind of big because the  kitchen's kind of big um i wanted seats  for all of my kids so there was five  chairs but one broke so  i had four  four kids only the four favorites we  just sit now  sorry  and then this is one of the things that  i love the most in our kitchen because  when our kids were little they would  always be want to be with mama mama mama  so i could set them up here either with  their little art project or just sit  here and they would always just sit and  talk to me and i think that that is like  some of my best